At that time I I look at this guy as a
god that if no one would like to get me
help with this I would go to the most
vile of the vilest of the yam in a
public place right no problem even being
handto hand with shaitan to getting this
out does he have any children any kids
himself yes yes and I'm making dua on
them as well making dua on his children
as well yes yes yes their atoms their
cells their bodies give him cancer
Myself and my wife, we know her as
Bushra, which is her real name. And some
of you guys and most of you guys have
never met her. I have met her face to
face on multiple occasions.
[Music]
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
before I start this video, I want to
say brothers and sisters, many of you
guys know this sister who's come out
with these accusations as TBA, as Aisha,
as
Sara. Many of you guys have heard her
stories behind the screens and her
accusations.
Myself and my wife, we know her as
Bushra, which is her real name. And some
of you guys and most of you guys have
never met her. I have met her face to
face on multiple occasions. And I'm
going to inshallah tell you guys exactly
what happened when I met her to when I
interviewed her and how this all
transpired for me finding out what
really happened. Now, in the beginning
of the video, guys, you heard some
things that were very, very disturbing.
And I can remember when I first heard
them, I was like, really? Would someone
go to these this level? No matter how
much you hate someone to say yes, yes,
yes to the his kids selves. Now, there
are people who kill people who kill
children like the Zidist regime. And
every single one of you guys and all of
us have come together in the past years
condemning the atrocities. And we have
been shocked over and over again when
Zionists have come and justified their
actions to us. So you guys know exactly
what I'm talking about. Now when
somebody comes and says not just making
general dua, you know, um I hope his
children this happens to them or
something bad happens to them. They go
to specific details by saying I make dua
against
theirelves. Who talks like that? Number
one. Number two, to come and say that he
sees hijab as a god is number two.
Number three, making dua that he himself
hijab gets cancer. And the most shocking
of them all, cuz all of them you can say
she's making dua. There's no active
thing that you can do. But no, she
actually tells her intentions of even
shaking hands with Shayan. Yeah. Not not
anyone. Shayan. And now obviously she
may maybe have attempted or not. But
then she says, "I will go to the most
vilest of the vile." And she did exactly
that by going to human satans and going
to the most vilest of the vile. And when
I'm saying this brothers and sisters, we
are talking about people who rip the
Quran, who spit on the Quran, who insult
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him,
who curse, who do everything and say
everything to insult Islam. Not only
that, these two individuals, Apos and
Rottenwood, who went to Israel, walked
the streets of Jerusalem and said, "We
don't see any genocide." mockingly while
the Palestinian kids were being blown
into pieces they said we don't see any
genocide. So you know what one thing
that I will give her she did go to whom
Shayan and she did went to the most
vilest of the vile she definitely
fulfilled that promise that she gave you
and all of us and she went to them and
told her tell them those stories we're
going to come to that and Salman yes
Dunya's ex-husband very shortly
inshallah and how he casually dismissed
in his latest video not even mentioning
about the dua against his Because yes,
their selves. I mean, these are
children. These are innocent kids. No
matter how much I can hate someone and
believe me, Apus and Rottenwood are
people that I make dua against and I ask
Allah to destroy them. Like if they were
destroyed in front of my eyes, I would
have popcorn. I would never, have you
ever seen me ever say that I would like
to see their children get
killed? Which human being would ever get
and pick on innocent children? unless
you have psychological issues. Now,
let's break this down step by step of my
occurrence and my wife's occurrence with
this sister where she messaged me, when
I met her, what she said, and how I fell
for her story. And this is how it
[Music]
transpired. How did I meet Bushra? Not
Toba, not Aisha. Very oddly and vividly
like it's so odd the name Aisha she
used. I wonder who asked her to use that
name. Muhammad and Aisha. It rings a
bell, doesn't it, guys? We're going to
come to the information and who she's
been working with behind the scenes to
use that name Aisha out of all names she
could use. She used Toba. She used Sarah
before, but for some odd reason, in this
very instance when she's becoming
public, she used the name Aisha. But we
will come to that later. At first, she
messaged me on Instagram. And I get many
messages on Instagram. And I prioritize
those who are on the verge of suicide.
they have a doubt or whatever it is for
that matter. I got this message. I saw
this message and my wife has access to
my phone. She read it etc. And she said
to me, "You know what? Stay out of it
because I don't know what she saw. I'll
be honest with you. I sometimes see and
I'm just like comment. I just say,
"Look, can you just read this for me and
see what it's about?" My wife read it
for me and she clearly told me, "Do you
know what Alli don't get involved
whatever it is, etc." And there are
sometimes sisters out there who just
come to me just for attention or
whatever it is for that matter. And I'm
not saying she did that or she didn't.
I'm just saying my wife clearly told me
Alli just stay away from this. I said no
problem. I'm not really bothered. But
later on she was persistent and when she
persisted I said you know what let's
have a look. She's a sister in Islam.
She has a concern. She seems like she's
very adamant. Something may have
happened. I consulted with my wife and I
said you know what let's just see what
the situation is. So my first occurrence
with her um after that was when she came
with Muhammad Tona. Yes. And came to me
and I sat down with her and I heard a
story. Muhammad came and said to me,
"This is what she's gone through. Hear a
story." I said, "No problem." I mean, if
it's coming from yourself, I mean, okay,
there must be something, you know,
serious for that matter. From what I
vividly uh remember or it might be that
I had that meeting first with Muhammad
and then the messages came one way or
another. Anyways, so I sat down with
her. I could remember in the little room
in Nostar Studios and I heard a story.
She told me this person and I said look
number one first thing first I don't
want to know who it is do not tell me
who it is because it can be like this
accusation by the way it can be someone
that I know and I don't want to be
biased I want to be just my loyalty is
to Allah and his messenger I have no
loyalty I'll be I'll be making it very
clear categorically clear not Muhammad
hijab not to not my dad not to my mom
not to my daughter not my sister I don't
have a sister I have no loyalty is clear
to nobody except Allah and his messenger
okay anything to do with that no
problem. So I said listen to me sister I
don't want to know the person's name
you're claiming this this happened
please tell me your story and the story
was similar from river I can remember
about marrying somebody miss marriage he
treated me like this girlfriend
boyfriend marriage hotel marriage all of
that stuff I said okay I mean when you
hear that from a sister and this is
another thing as men we fall into
sometimes we can be very naive we
believe it and um I'm not going to
mention the the I'm going to be talking
about but he does marriage counseling he
says one of the mistakes that we would
do is when a sister comes in and she
starts crying. We automatically think
the husband is wrong and this is wrong.
Ali said in order for you to understand
justice you have to hear both sides and
this is where I failed as a human being.
I failed because when I heard a story
and she's told me this I sympathized. I
was upset. I was angry. I was like which
human being would do these things to the
sister? I was upset. So was Muhammad.
same he was when I was with him he was
upset. Yeah. Now moving forward then
afterwards there was a communication
through Instagram if I'm not mistaken.
After that she asked to come and meet me
in my da table. I said no problem sister
but I got my wife. Alhamdulillah.
Actually she said can I come? I said you
can come. I've said if you're free you
not doing nothing. Leave the kids out
your mom. She came with me. Actually no
she we she came with the kids if I'm not
mistaken. She came and um this sister
Bushra said that she would be more
comfortable. Alhamdulillah to me it's me
it's better it's a public place anyway
it's not like we meet anywhere private
no problem my wife came we went to
coffee conc we sat down we sat down and
we spoke one thing my wife noticed was
this she said this to me actually
herself she said she didn't even
acknowledge my wife's presence there
like for some and I'm not saying
anything she like she seemed very like
to me she seemed like she wanted blood
like I could just see from her eyes she
wanted nothing but blood and my wife
even said like it's as if like her body
positioning. It's as if my wife didn't
even exist. And I even met her daughter,
beautiful young girl. She was playing
with the kids, etc. We bought some ice
cream, etc. They were sitting
there. That was my second occurrence
with her. I spoke to her. And the third
occurrence was when I heard a story when
she told me, you know, she uh was lied
into getting a secret marriage. She
didn't want this and ra all these kind
of stories. And I thought to myself,
subhan Allah, whoever this person is in
the da scene, I don't care. I said, I
want the public to hear your voice. Now,
I could have come and say, "Hold on a
second. You know, it's in the Dao scene.
It might be someone that I know. Let me
be biased, you know, cuz you know, if
we're biased, I would say, you know
what? Sorry, sister. Your story is lied.
Don't contact me. Don't message me. Go
away. Get it." No. I took her voice and
I said, "Let her have a voice and
express herself. Only one condition.
Because it's an accusation, no names are
going to be mentioned because it's an
accusation. I don't know who it's about,
etc. But you want to voice your opinion.
No problem." So however later on I did
find out who it was but I still went
ahead with the interview because it's I
said look it's an accusation and it's my
duty now to find out the other side cuz
the name has been mentioned now which I
did not want it to be mentioned I let
her have a her voice now she said that
she did not want to get into a look
let's let's read from the website
clearly so the question is asked did I
agree to a secret marriage she starts
off with never Now listen very
carefully. Two words I want you to pick
up on. Never and secrecy. Never and
secrecy. This is very bold for someone
someone coming and saying never and
secrecy. Now let's read some messages
which will which when I saw and when in
this very studio because when these
accusations were unfolding and then I
happened to know the name she mentioned
I didn't ask for the name. I told her
clearly I don't want to know the name.
When she mentioned me the name I still
went ahead and did done the interview.
The most blame way they think that
people come and say hate to me is hold
on a second here. Actually what you done
was a violation towards your friend
hijab. And I was you know actually
you're right because if you think about
it my bias was actually towards her when
I didn't know who it was and when I knew
who it was I said look in order for me
to be just which actually I was unjust
if you think about it. I was thinking I
was just by hearing the story this whole
interview that we took and then I came
to this very house and then I played
this thing. I said somebody approached
me. Yes. And this was my indirect way of
getting hijab to like see if there's an
you know he can he who can come out if
this is someone that he even knows. I
wanted to see does he even know her. We
played the full interview and hijab said
to me bro I I know this this this this
this this voice. I know this woman. And
I said okay who? And she said come let
me he said come and let me show you.
This is the messages that he showed me
that made me change my mind. It made me
embarrassed. It made me realize the
mistake that I did because to me of not
wanting to be unjust, I I ended up being
just I ended up being unjust towards
hijab. So if you think about it, if I
have any loyalty, I would have done the
opposite, right? Would I not come and
say to her, look, you're a liar. No, no,
I actually had to apologize hijab and
say, bro, I'm sorry. It's just I didn't
want to be biased and I took the
interview, whatever. This is what he
said. I want you guys to listen
carefully, please.
Yeah. Could I ask you today, please? I
need some advice. So, Hijab is replying
saying, I know a 28 28-year-old brother,
Tunisian, not married, no kids. I've
known him for 20 years. Would you
consider him for
marriage? Okay, you can see she says,
"Thanks for thinking I could be suitable
for someone you've known for 20 years. I
would consider I can't see the text here
that has high religious level and
practice." The next message, sorry about
those texts. I got emotional l and then
hijab replies listen I honestly think
what you deserve and what is most likely
to ensure that you don't go through
heartbreak or oppression is a normal
monogous relationship I must give you
this advice otherwise I would be
cheating
you third message I can now listen Kevin
this is very key cuz remember she said
never for secret marriage and secrecy I
can go for a religious man inshallah and
give up on
equality. Did you hear that? Okay. Now,
I just don't want to be I just don't
want to be cut off in case she finds out
with no mistake of mine. And then I
would still go for a religious man even
he has to cut me off if she finds out
with no mistakes of mine. Now there's an
issue that I have. Let's suppose this
marriage actually happened. Let's go
with argument sake. Even though clearly
hijab is denying it, this marriage
didn't happen. Okay, let's go with
it. The text here says, I just don't
want to be cut off. So, she's first
expressing, I don't want to be cut off
if your wife finds out, which in in it
tells you clearly that she is agreeing
to a secret marriage. You see, it's a
secret marriage. Number two, and then
she, this is why I found it a little bit
odd. In the same message, she twists and
says, "And then I would still go for a
religious." So, okay, one second. First,
you're saying I don't want a to happen,
but if a was to happen, I will still go
ahead with it. Says, "And I will still
go for a religious man even if he has to
cut me off if she finds out with no
mistake of mine." I don't know if you
guys find this troubling, but number
one, the first point is this. The
evidences does not match. First you're
saying never to secrecy. Then you are
saying that which again which is
actually very weird because sister
Bushra because I've met you face to face
Bushra you here are saying this and
guess who else is actually not only just
calling you out and showing the the the
evidence not matching
here. Apos the very vile Satan that you
said you'll go to the worst of the worst
you went to him. He's even actually
having a go at this an enemy of Islam
who you went to. He's even saying and
blaming you. Blaming you and saying you
are as to as much to blame if this
marriage happened that you went there
and said, "Oh, it's a secrecy." He's
actually saying to you what you did was
not even honorable. This is an enemy of
Islam, the most vile of the man who
rifts the Quran on the Quran, telling
you that you went to him, by the way,
him and David Wood, which we're going to
come to a bit later. All the evidences
how you've been working with the enemies
of Islam, not only about this story, but
trying to aid them with evidences used
against Islam, which is I'm not doing of
you. I'm saying it's so your evidences
does not match. When I saw these
messages, I was so angry at myself
because what you told me and what came
out to be which is these evidences was
what I'm not going to say. There's two
options here. Either you are an outright
liar or number two, you have
psychological issues. I cannot put
anything under. If I want to assume the
best in you, I'll say you have
psychological issues or there was
something happened. whatever it is, I
just don't know how you can come and to
me and Muhammad and tell us this story
and then after that we find the truth of
stuff that you haven't said to these
accusations and this as an accusation
that you married him and the hotel
marriages and all of this case with no
single evidence. We took your word. We
believed in you as our sister. We didn't
come and say get lost, you attention
seeker. I sat down with you. I am a busy
man. I've got I've got a family. I've
got three daughters. I've got kids. I
have daughters. Yes, I took your words
seriously. I sat down with you. I gave
you my time. Even though my wife said,
"Look, don't get involved. Stay away."
Even then, I said, "Nope. Look, she's
our sister. I came and I done an
interview. I listened to your story. My
wife listened to you. We was there with
your daughter. Subhan Allah. A beautiful
young girl. Subhan Allah. And many other
things that you didn't even tell the
public, which we are going to talk about
very soon, inshallah." So after that I
apologized to hijab and I said forgive
me because not wanting to be biased and
not wanting to be uh unjust uh to to to
have justice I was unjust to you. So
this is an if Allah is my witness this
all happened in this very house. So that
is the reason why I did not release the
video. This is the reason why I actually
even deleted it. And subhan Allah I even
tried to retrieve it. We couldn't. And
I'll show you the messages here. Yeah.
Let's go. Let's go. Subhan Allah. Now a
you know bro that that that is gone
actually long time. That's gone a long
time bro. Um subhan
Allah. Yeah that's gone a long time
actually. Long time. What I might do? I
might Let me see if I can try and get it
recovered but I doubt it, bro. It's been
so long. I doubt I can get it back. We
couldn't. So this is phase two. Now
we're going to move on to phase three of
her outright working with the enemies of
Islam and you are going to be shocked
and one thing that you said which um cuz
I didn't hear the thing of I saw him as
God but if you remember Bushra sister
Bushra if you remember when we sat down
with you and my wife and I was talking
to you said I saw Muhammad hijab like
he's Abu Bakr. Now when I heard this I
was thinking like I mean Abu Bakr like I
mean no respect to hijab you know I'm
not I was just like excuse me like Abu
Bakr like I don't understand like why
would you hold some human being like
human as well but you know someone to
that level I was shocked this showed me
that there was a deep level rooted
obsession because for you to message and
give because you're basically giving
hints to hijab in that message I'll be
honest with you you're basically saying
whoever this man is you know if he takes
me as a second wife etc I don't mind
forgoing my rights this is the this is a
another level of msar so to my dear
sisters who are supporting sister bushra
etc look I'm not saying whatever she
went I don't know what she went through
that hijab's thing clearly it's nothing
to do with him but simple question my
dear sisters defending her no problem
and actually there was one sister who
messaged me on Instagram like yeah your
friend done this I said are you married
she goes yeah I said what if she
approached your husband and said I don't
mind being a secret even if your wife
finds
She stopped messaging me. I said, I
thought so. If she messaged your husband
and said, I don't mind being a secret
second wife. I don't mind that if your
wife finds out that you can leave me.
Look, I'll be honest with you. Yes.
Okay. I've been in situations where
people have been in polygamous marriages
and mainly sisters will say, "Look, if
your wife finds out, are you going to
leave me?" Um, I might do. Sorry, I
don't want it. So to me in that
instance, brothers and sisters, it shows
that you are
obsessively in like you just like you're
pursuing him when you are accusing him
of pursuing you. That's point number
one. And not only that, Ton Muhammad
Tone, he's got an audio recording we're
going to play for you. Now about this
case, when sister Bush reached out to me
and she told me about the marriage
between her and Muhammad hijab, I
believed her. Later, Muhammad denied
this
marriage. Now, on my side, I tried to
speak to sister Bushra. I tried to
advise her. Also, I tried to make her
feel that she's hurt and to calm her
emotions down. But none of my efforts
made any difference to her. And at the
end of the day, Allahel is the one who
judge between all our affairs. And
Allahel is the one who just and fair. So
I will leave this matter to Allah. Also
my brother, I don't want to get involved
in this matter any further. So please my
brother don't contact me for this matter
anymore. Do you think I'm going to
coersse? You think I'm Do you think I'm
scared of Mhammed or Zan or anyone? Do
you think somebody's going to And to be
honest, my psychology actually if
somebody threatens me, if someone says
sweet words to me, I might work with it.
Yeah. But if someone threatens me, I
actually I work the opposite way. Yeah.
Okay. So listen to me. I don't care.
Like I said, Mary before as well. I'm
telling you exactly what transpired.
Okay. So, before someone comes and says,
you know, hijab's got a gun. You can't
see it be behind is telling me what to
do. Yeah. Okay. Muhammad Ton and myself
both fell for this. And Dunya's ex, I'm
going to call you Duny's ex. Okay. You
are so obsessed with your ex. You've
made your whole Dunya Dunya. And I'm
going to come to you very later because
we are going to be exploring many
episodes to come about Dunya's
accusations about you and how she claims
that you committed Zena, my friend. Yes.
And I'm not saying you did. I'm just
putting it out there. We'll come to it
[Music]
later. So brothers and sisters, as I
told you guys before, when sister Bushra
came to me, I heard her story. I heard
her out. We listened to her with my
family, my children. we because we took
her seriously and she is our sister in
Islam. But brothers and
sisters, this matter has become personal
to me. Not because hijab is my friend or
my brother, but rather the messages that
I'm about to show you now will leave you
jaw-dropped. because this matter has
become about Islam. Because what you
read, what you what I'm about to read
now is a message from her account and
we're going to prove to you is from her
account saying the following. Hi David,
I have some important information to
share with you that you might you may
find useful to share about Islam. How
can I contact you? When I saw this
message, this matter became very
personal to me because I told you guys
before my loyalty is to Allah and his
messenger. And since Bushra, you have
decided to throw Islam under the bus.
I'm not going to do the same thing and I
won't. You have not said here, I have
information to share about Muhammad
hijab or Ali Dawa or whoever for that
matter. You have directly made a
statement of kufur. Share what
information about Islam with who is
this? Are you sharing information with
sister Katijah who wants to know how to
defend Islam? Rather you are going to
the vilest of the vile and you are
shaking hands with Shayan and that
Shayan betrayed you. So from this
messages guys for somebody to drop so so
low no matter how much you hate one
individual for whatever reason it is to
go and say that you will be sharing
information that an enemy of Islam who
laughs and mocks the death of
Palestinian children who have been blown
into pieces who rips the Quran spits on
the Quran who burns the Quran who
insults your messenger day and
night. And we are going to take the
testimony of this woman seriously.
Bushra it has become personal now. Now
what we're going to do brothers and
sisters is we're going to show you the
first mistake of the many mistakes I
made but one slip up of a message a fake
photoshopped message that we have to
give it to our brother Salman Duna's
ex-husband should we say who came out
and said that this was
photoshopped. Just one thing you missed
there, brother Salman Shasi Duna's
ex-husband. Yeah, that photoshopped
message that you missed out on your
video to inform your viewers was done by
Bushra herself. And here is the evidence
in this relationship and so on. I want
you to help me make things easy. I
really want this to happen. So I thought
like at that time I I look at this guy
as a god like cuz I I trust him
enough. I I I was like I didn't see at
all anything wrong that's going to
happen. This is for me like the story of
the marriage of we're going to show you
now the correlations and the connections
that her channel had when they when she
even contacted David Wood. She has been
on multiple da life channels of Dawise
brother Hashim Mansour Shahazim and many
of these duat withahad about the Quran.
So
sister, could could I ask you um so in
terms of the Quran and its preservation,
do you have an issue with that or are
you convinced that the Quran is
preserved? Well, I'm trying to
understand here, right? But I'm just
asking you. I'm just asking you in terms
of where Yes, I do have an issue. Yes, I
do have an issue. Like as I said in the
beginning, all of all of it because
that's fine. So now, like I said before,
Duna's ex-husband, which we're going to
come to a bit later, inshallah. So he
said that this was photoshopped. Yes, it
would be nice if you told him that it
was photoshopped by your client, Bushra.
It says here, you have time to see
everyone in your life except me. I just
want to sit down and talk. I am not
Shuli or Dwitz. I am not your enemy. Now
you might be thinking okay Ali what's
the proof here? Uh one little thing if
you see the reply that Muhammad hijab
apparently gives sister please have
self-dignity leave the matter to Allah.
This was on 10th August 2023. This was
this happened before October the 7th
which meaning that hijab did not know or
did not have any communication with
Shuli or Derswitz. So this is a direct
fabrication. Now where was this ed?
Where was this put on? On Bushra's
channel. And here is evidence we're
going to show you where she had to take
down multiple videos randomly. And
somebody who's from the Arab world asks
her the following question. And look at
what she says. This person whose message
who's in Arabic, it's written Arabic
says in a nutshell is asking Bushra
where did those messages go? Because
they were quite strong points. In a
nutshell, she's saying about the
accusations and d. Now, reading that in
Arabic, you're assuming that is a
sister, a righteous mmin behind there
asking for her to aid her sister. Not
really. Cuz if we look closely, guys, it
says Proverbs 1 Christian. And I don't
know if you guys have seen a pattern,
but I've seen a pattern all across
Dunya's ex-husband's videos and all
across everywhere. Christians are
flooding the comment section. Now, why
would they do such a thing? Why would
the enemies of Islam do such a thing?
All right, I know why. Because Bushra,
you have been aiding them like you said,
you're going to go to the vilest of the
vile and the most satanic of the satanic
and you've shaken hands with them and
you are not only doing that, you have
even told David Wood that you are
willing to share information about
Islam. Bushra, don't worship yourself.
Allah says in the Quran, have you seen
the one who takes his own desire as his
own? Your desire to take Muhammad hijab
down for whatever reason it is, it has
gone beyond him. You have now directly
have allied yourself with the enemies of
Islam. Now, we're going to provide you
evidences how this channel is connected
to her and she took those videos down.
Not only that, forget me. Take it out.
Not the horse's mouth, the Satan's own
mouth. David Wood. Here is what he said
and how he confirms this YouTube channel
is directly connected to Bushra, your
channel. Here's the video. Uh, it's been
verified. The woman here, Aisha,
um, she's calling herself Aisha. Um,
she's actually in the chat. Uh, her
channel is Faith. I think it was
Thaddius who said that he verified that
it's actually her. But she says, "I'm
the woman in question. When I said he
ruined my life for years, it's because
we were in contact for 3 years prior to
the marriage, and I have been fighting
for 2 years to get justice." So, what
you heard there, brothers and sisters,
of these two Satan, these two bastards,
one bastard down there who uh raised
£100,000 and put his wife in hijab,
accepted Christianity, that other
bastard there, um clearly admitting that
this is her channel. It's been verified.
It's her channel. And what we showed you
on the screens shows that it was her
channel and she took down the videos. So
much so her Christian friends now cuz
they've been allyship, they have
Christian friends asking her, "Where did
those go?" And she's saying, "Oh, no,
it's going to come back in." Yeah. She
went on multiple daer channels live and
went there to talk about the doubt that
she had. Another verse in Quran which
says had it been from other source than
from Allah they would have found so many
contradiction in it. So so when do you
when you read the Quran do you see any
contradiction?
Well uh if the alterations weren't so
many I'm not talking about any
alterations. I'm saying when you read
the Quran, do you see any any any
contradictions, contradictions in the
oneness of Allah? Contradiction in the
prophethood of of Mos of Isa, of Ibraim,
of Noah, of of the Amy, contradiction in
the rulings, in the in the legislative
in Islamic legislative. Do you see any
contradiction in in inah in uh in
uh inheritance in all of this? Anything
in the Quran? Anything in the Quran?
Hashim, what's up? What's up? Um sorry,
what did you say about it? Hashim,
what's up? Please continue. Yeah. Yeah.
So I I don't think I'm well I personally
don't see any kind of contradictions at
all but this to me this doesn't negate
the questioning around al alterations
because we may find you know you know a
book and then we have a few verses. Now
we don't have a problem with doubts.
People can have doubts. It's
understandable. The point the problem
that we have is the intention. What
intentions and what plotting are you
coming with with those doubts? Because
when the brothers answer your questions
logically and rationally, you persist on
the Quran's preservation and it's not
preserved. Where is these ideas coming
from? That is the point. Now, brothers
and sisters, when you We're going to end
the segment on this before we come to
Duna's ex-husband. Yes. Ex-husband who
so obsessed with the dunya. Yes. He's
made his whole world dunya. This man,
we're gonna come to him now. But before
that, you just need to remember
something because it reminds me reminds
me of the ay of the Quran and Bushra.
I'm telling this to you. I know you and
I know you're going to be watching this.
Okay. May Allah subhanaa tala guide you.
Yes. You went and shook hand. You said
with the most vile of the vials, Satan.
You will shake hand with Shayan. Yeah,
no problem. Guess what? What does Shayan
do on your What does he say? He says
that I am free. He frees himself. I am
free. I only called you. And you know
with Shayan, you can say, you know what,
he's the one actually calling the people
to evil. You went to Satan's doorstep.
You went to evil. He didn't even call
you. You went to them. And here's a clip
of one of the Satans. These bastard. His
face has got Latin on it. You can see.
Yeah. Look what he said. And look how he
actually humiliated you. Well, it just
reminded me of the ayah where you and
them for to them for aid and they just
chewed you, used you and spat you. Okay.
All right. This is what they actually
done to you. Look at how he humiliates
you for your deception of secret misss
marriage. Why are you Why are you Why
are you blaming the victim? She's not a
victim, man. I mean, let's face it. Um,
I think I think some people need to uh
be ready to be criticized for some
really stupid decisions that they make,
especially and I'm not saying I'm not
saying that she did something stupid and
misjudging character and, you know, uh,
doing something, you know, getting
herself into it, but it also involves
her being, uh, deceptive and dishonest
and basically engaging in a plot for her
own benefit and her own pleasure as it
seems in um, you know, going or hiding
it from uh, his family and all that. So
the very people that you went to are now
blaming you. Maybe Bushra, you should
take accountability for your actions.
Maybe you should because right now I'll
be honest with you, I have no kind of
mercy towards you because you've brought
Islam into this. Not Muhammad hijab. No,
with all due respect, you have put and
tried your best to throw Islam under the
bus. This is why the problem has become
personal. Now if it was about hijab, I
can just come and do a video and say
it's an allegation I've made you. No,
you have took this a step forward. and
the very Satan that you shook hands with
stabbed you right behind you. What did
you gain now? What did you gain?
Nothing. So on this segment, we're going
to finish this inshallah with the Satan
betraying you know the very person who's
gone to them for aid. So like you said
Bushra, you will go to the most vilest
of the v vile. You will shake hands with
Satan. You've done that and here is what
you got deserved. Now, we're going to
move on to the next segment where we
break down the ex-husband of Dunya and
his false
[Music]
accusations. In this segment, brothers
and sisters, we are going to be in
talking about Salman. Salman, the
exhusband of Dunya. And before we get to
the sisters, he brought forth an
individual who's been working with
enemies of Islam who has clearly clearly
with a passion with rage have said yes
yes yes I make dua against his
children's selves atoms makes dua that
hijab gets cancer says I will work with
shan says that I will go and work with
the most vile of the vile individuals
who who have admitted and said that he
saw she saw hijab as a god and
personally to myself in front of my wife
told me that he she even saw him as Abu
Bakr. Brother, now you might think to
yourself, does it get any worse than
that? Yes, it does. I'm going to read a
message for you guys. This is a a camera
angle of a helicopter, an Israeli
helicopter who was shooting at innocent
Palestinians. And she makes this comment
which I find very bizarre and very odd.
And bear in mind, this is the client of
Salman, this so-called righteous,
honorable man who's sticking up for the
oppressed. Or is he someone that is
obsessed with his ex-wife and the rage
that he has against her has caused him
to be unjust against others? Let's read
this. It it gives you the feeling of
doing things just to experience them.
Psychopathy, narcissism, and sadism.
Anyone who would be in that position and
have been restricted with his life from
authority has low self-esteem would have
a great urge to press the button and
kill them. Now you might be thinking to
yourself, who makes such a absurd weird
comment? And if you think about pressing
the button, it reminds me of the two
Israelis in a podcast saying, "If we
could press the button and wipe off
everyone in Gaza, we would." So I'm just
thinking, Bushra, why are you talking in
that manner? Not against hijab, not
against Islam. If you already thrown
them both under the bus or whatever for
that matter, you are not talking about
the Palestinian people who in that
camera angle are going to they are
fighting over food because they are
starving to death. And you happen to
make this comment. So, Salman, next time
a client comes to you or any individual
who can make up stories, say things that
they've told us and then we find out the
truth. Next time before you jump the gun
and humiliate your own self cuz which
you have because you have brought no
evidence. What evidence did you bring? I
can make up the same evidences against
you with dunya and use chat GPT or AI.
in a matter of five minutes I would have
all kind of messages your voice
recordings which are generated by AI in
matter of seconds or minutes. So
therefore we have proven to you that
there is no evidence. Not only that we
have shown you a forged um photoshopped
message that you yourself admitted the
only little key factor that you missed
out which was what that it was Bushra
herself who made that and she took it
down from her channel. Maybe you asked
her to take it down. Did you Salman? Oh,
and before I forget, in that very
message, there is a voice note right
underneath. Why don't you press play,
bro? Why don't you press play? Because
you know very clearly that you were
admitted it was forged. The question we
ask because we have debates with
Christians all day all night. The very
Christians the enemies of Islam that
Bushra went to and the very Christians
that are on your comment sections with
David Wood who insults Islam that he's
got free 400 likes and you don't even
have the decency towards Islam to delete
his message. Who are you working with?
And what objectives what gains do you
have out of this? That's the question
that I want to ask you Salman. Yes, you
know very clearly because when we talk
to Christians, we point out a single
verse of the Bible and say if this is
corrupted, your whole Bible is in a big
question and we ask you the same thing.
If this has been forged, what else has
been forged? You need to ask that
question to yourself before jumping the
gun, Salman. And if this the yard stick,
if this is the criteria that we are
going to use, we are all doomed. All
doomed. So was yourself because son man,
you're not just going to get away. We're
going to use your standards bit by bit,
one by one against you. Not in this
video. We've got videos coming for you.
How? We're going to be listening to
Duna's account of the things that she
accuses you of. And we are going to take
her word for it, just to use your
standards. And we're going to be seeing
in the coming days when I release those
videos and see the stuff that she's
accused you of of committing Zena there
being video footage. Um that you used to
beat her. Yes, you used to beat her.
Again, we're going to use your standards
and have her say on it because I done a
video defending you against her. Yes.
Little did I know that when I found out
the moment you was threatening hijab
when I found out that you was taking
these allegations seriously I thought to
myself where is your evidences and I was
waiting for you to bring the evidences
until this day many people are
commenting and saying it's been the
first video the second video the third
video where is your evidences man where
is it otherwise anyone any shape form
can make accusations towards anybody use
AI whatever it's for that matter We are
still waiting for your so-called
evidences which you do not have none.
Unlike yourself, we have shown you
evidences, connections. Yes, both
internally and externally connecting her
voice to the number her speaking uh
coming to live platforms. We've matched
her voice. We've put it through AIS is
the same person who spoke to on the live
stream on Daw Wise and uh many other
platforms that she's gone on to. We have
shown you all the evidences and we'll
show you again. Check these clips.
No, I think it's the wrong number that
you dial. Oh, no. It's better. As you
can see, we have clearly demonstrated
and proven to you that we are talking
about the same individual and we have
given you evidences. Do you have
something like that? If you don't, what
is your motivations? Now, the only thing
that I can bring it down to which I see
a common factor with you and Bushwa is
that you are obsessed. You are obsessed
with dunya as Bushra is obsessed with
hijab. And that rage has clouded your
judgment of being just. So much so that
your friend demonstrated this in a voice
clip. Let's listen to it for oursel. On
the other hand, and I need you to also
understand this. I'm not going to be
quiet. Uh every single one of us has
been burned by religious uh powerful
figures uh because of whatever reason.
And unfortunately when people when they
get to that of becoming famous um
unfortunately unfortunately the vast
majority start to engage in in wrong
behavior and I ask Allahh he protects
you from that. I'm not saying that you
did it. I'm just asking questions so
that you can help us so that we can help
you at the end. But again I get it. You
don't trust us. You don't know who we
are. We could just turn around and and
basically backstab you and betray you. I
understand that and I would probably be
hesitant as well if I was in your
situation. I don't know what else to do.
I'm just giving you the lifeline. If you
want to have a video chat with me, if
you want to get to know me, if you want
to just, you know what? Maybe that's
what it will take for you to feel
comfortable with me. So, you heard that
for yourself. Every single one of us
have been burnt by religious figures.
Meaning what? The enemy here is
religious figures. Just because you had
a bad experience, which you claim by the
way, because right now there's a big
question mark on everything that you
say. Yes. because you've been burnt
which that means is that basically you
are number one from the get-go by
because now it's like anybody that comes
with a religious figure you're like okay
good I've been burnt by the religious
figure I'm going to take evidences
forward even if I cannot verify them
okay and using words like we have
cornered you what kind I mean which
Muslim that comes with you know we
wanted the best and we wanted hijab to
come and say his side speaks like that
and says we have cornered you that shows
malicious intent that's the reason why
the evidence that we brought bring forth
is going to be well with it's damning
already for you there is a big question
mark on you and not only that Muhammad
is not the only person you've attacked
you've accused Omar Sulman Omar of freem
mixing and flirting with your ex-wife
again these were slanderous cuz when I
spoke to Omaran he took an off by Allah
and I spoke to you and I'm not going to
do what you've done because I sent you a
private message which not that I have a
problem you mentioned in public I had
nothing to hide I'm happy that you did
but the point here is the principle you
go and read a private message. Do you
remember you sent me a message few
messages about your ex? Yeah. And you
said to me, please like that. I entrust
you with this. I do not break that
trust. I'm not if I want which I hate
what you've done for the sake of Allah
by aiding the enemies of Islam with no
evidence with this sister Bushra that
you have not even met in your life. Yes.
I'm not going to do the same and reveal
those messages because I gave you my
word. I'm not going to allow that to go
against a principle that I tried to live
by. I could easily come and say, "Hold
on a second. Should I mention this and
this and this that you've mentioned to
me in in private messages?" I'm not
going to do that. I'm not going to
forfeit it because I sent you a private
message. You made it public. It shows
what kind of you have no integrity. Not
only that, number two, Muhammad clearly
told you do not mention his name. You
disregarded it. What kind of a man are
you? If somebody gives their word to you
and says to you, listen, whatever he
said, which he was duped into as well,
which after you heard the recording,
which he clearly said that he was duped
into it just like I did, and I believe
you was, but you brought this to public
and made this whole fiasco and this
whole scandal that the enemies of Islam
are using to insult the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him. Okay? Why? Because a
deluded woman who wants revenge at any
cost that she will curse the cells of
the children and work with Satan and the
most evil people so much so that she
makes bizarre weird comments against
Palestinians being blown into pieces
which I find bizarre. You are in hand in
hand with her because look you might say
I'm not. She's holding the hand of
Shayan and you are holding her hand. You
are complicit in it as much as she is
and you brought this to the public. So
you're going to pay the price and this
is not a threat. This is just us telling
you Salman the ex of dunya that we are
going to use your standards against you
and we are going to hear the story of
dunya and we're going to bring it to the
public and say guys we're not saying it
is true or not. Here's the story of
dunya and here is what she accuses her
ex-husband son man of and let's see how
you like that. the same standards here.
The same standards, an I for an I,
because you came with lies and
accusations. At least you
yourself tell us that Duna made these
accusations against you. Duna is
concerned due to the fact San has been
showing up at her venues and causing
disturbances. This is another egregious
lie as I never showed up to any of her
venues or caused any disturbances. As
with the growing list of lies, this is
another claim rooted in lies which she
cannot provide any evidence for nor
furnish any witnesses. Bring forth your
proofs of adultery in our marriage.
After all, you told your friend Nahila
that I was caught on camera. Go ahead,
release it to the public. Yet, in
Hijab's case, he has inexplicably
lowered the evidentiary standard,
repeating at least twice in his message
that her word is her evidence. Bring
forth your proofs of physical violence
in our marriage. Bring forth your proofs
of your ex-sister-in-law trying to run
you over in the parking lot on three
different occasions. Bring forth your
proofs. And if you cannot, by Allah, may
you always be known as a wicked and
vicious liar. And the last thing that I
will leave with you guys, brothers and
sisters, is Salman's video recordings of
him saying and telling us the
accusations that Dunya accuses him of
and how passionately and aggressively
and how how emotionally he's touched by
these accusations. Yet he does the same
to Omar Suliman, Muhammad Hijab, and
even people who are much older than him
such as Yaser Bjaz. This man, as you can
see, is throwing these accusations left,
right, center. And do you think it's
going to stop Muhammad hijab? No, it's
not. His rage that he has for his
ex-wife has blinded his justice. Hear it
for yourself. Bring forth your proofs.
And if you cannot, by Allah, may you
always be known as a wicked and vicious
liar amongst the people on this earth
and amongst the angels. until you
repent, until you issue a public apology
to myself, to my wife, to my family, and
to all the people you have slandered and
harmed. And you heard that for yourself,
guys. Lastly, I want to say this. Go to
his comment sections. Majority of the
people are enemies of Islam, Christians.
Now to the Christians out there, just as
a little message for you guys, no
scandal, false, true, not true, whatever
for that matter, can take away from the
problem of the
trinity. Look, I just want to make this
clear to you guys, okay? Because you
guys cannot deal with the trinity
argument and people are leaving Islam.
There's a new pure research that shows
uh that people are leaving Christianity
um in the millions, okay? So, I want to
tell you guys, don't think that this is
a bullet against Islam for that matter.
It isn't. So all I'm going to say is die
in your rage because not only that these
comments that have been everywhere you
can see it majority of them are from
Christians Christians. And not only that
what I find bizarre is that Salman
doesn't even have the audacity the
respect to Islam. David Wood the
absolute crackhead who's talking about
his mom went through this and his
comment is there with 400 likes. Salman
who responds he responds to many people
by the way. Yeah. When people say
something he doesn't like. No, I've got
evidence and it's going to be damning,
etc., etc. For some odd reason, leaves
the comment of the biggest enemy of
Islam. It's like Abu Jah leaves a
comment and he leaves that there and
doesn't delete it. He responds to
everyone else, Muslims who are
questioning saying, "Where's your
evidence? Where's your evidence?" He
questions and says, "No, no, I've got
some something coming. Something coming.
Isn't that been coming?" Yes, like
Father Christmas. When's it coming? But
when David Wood and the enemies of Islam
comment, they don't even delete it.
Muslim mom who done a video, may Allah
bless her. She want to do her own video.
No problem. This little this
intellectual uh, what's his
name? Um, Samir, the one that speaks
like that. Yeah. Okay. That little
major. I was looking for us Google.
Yeah. That flipping clown. He made a
comment. The sister we informed. They
deleted immediately. Salman. The enemies
of Islam are commenting and making up
lies and you are leaving them there. You
are as bad as Bushra. I'm going to leave
it there. Sisters, we have provided you
all evidences, firsthand accounts of
myself and my wife meeting Bushra. I
trusted you. I treated you like my own
sister and I took on your word and you
lied and deceived myself. You lied and
deceived Muhammad Ton and you have now I
don't know if you've deceived Salman
looks like he's on board with you uh
with shaking hands with Shayan. Uh but
for that matter, brother and sisters,
all I'm going to say is inshallah and
one thing that I was going to miss the
just to touch upon that inshallah.
Brothers and sisters, we've got a woman
which I've given you a track record of
the very bizarre things she's saying and
there seems to be a psychological issue.
It has to be is asking Muhammad Jab, a
6'6 guy to come and do mahala with her.
Now when you do mahabah, this is
something that is directed to the
Christians in the Quran. So she's asking
that Muhammad hijab and his family and
kids that she wants their sales to be
cancered or whatever and she comes there
with her daughter. I've seen a little
daughter and she wants hijab to invoke a
curse on a single mother. Yes. And a six
or seven year old girl. I mean I I I
don't know what to say to this. You want
us to come forward and curse another
Muslim, a single mother with her
daughter on on what camera? She doing on
camera at some uh after effects or I
don't understand. It's very very
bizarre. So that's why we do not take
this claim very seriously because a
woman who said things like that I will
not take anything she says seriously
from this moment onward. That's all we
need to say in sisters and this matter
comes to an end and we will inshallah
continue our works and those behind the
scenes who are coming together with the
Zionists and the enemies of Islam and
whoever is for that matter alhamdulillah
you will not stop our course we are
going to carry on your false accusations
and lies only further proof that we are
trying our best we're not perfect best
believe we're not perfect but believe me
what you accuse us of nowhere near are
we those people so brothers and sisters
I ask you guys to fear Allah subhana wa
tala when it comes to this matter
inshallah and Do not aid your brother or
your sister. Yes. Against the Shayan
inshallah.